>> With this in mind, your next assignment requires you to use the data file
you've parsed to render the few images on the screen. You're going to need to
fill out the two functions below to properly draw images on the screen. Now,
before you get started, let's talk about something real quick. Note that, before
now, your artists were actually generating assets referencing loose files. And
artists create some sort of texture, they put it on disk, and then they
reference an object to that texture. Well, of course, there's a post-process.
We've all crammed that all into a small little box, and we now have a missing
correlation. The artist file still is going to reference the loose asset. But
we've got it sitting around in a larger texture. How do we make a connection
between the two? The drawSprite function needs to fix this. It assumes that it's
going to be given a spritename, which represents the name of the loose asset
file as well as the position X and position Y on where it wants to render it on
the canvas. Since we're just given a spitename, we need to map where that
spritename exists inside of the atlases that we've loaded. Now, for your
benefit, we're going to help you out with this. Taking a look at the top of the
file, we define a global dictionary object that represents every sprite sheet
that's been loaded. In the load function for sprite sheet, we go ahead and add
this sprite sheet into the global array, setting the sheet name as the key for
the dictionary element. What this will allow you to do is when you're given the
spritename inside of the draw function, you can iterate through all of the
sprite sheets and for each sprite sheet, determine whether or not the given
spritename exists in the sprites that have been defined for that sheet. This
should be pretty straightforward since we've already covered the defined sprite
function and you already have a list that includes a name. Once the drawSprite
function figures out what atlas this given sprite is actually in, it can pass
that data to drawSpriteInternal, handing off the sprite information, what atlas
sheet its coming from, as well as the position X and Y that was given to us from
drawSprite. Drawspriteinternal should actually do the heavy lifting of
positioning the element, and drawing it to the world, taking advantage of the
draw image API that we just covered with all of its new fancy bells and whistle
parameters.